[Applause]
can we please hear it for amber
you know she and i spent some time among
the leaders who are here we toured the
facility
and we were just backstage and she was
sharing with me
a bit about her life and
you know she didn't have it easy growing
up
but she talked about how the house of
labor
how the men and women of labor saw in
her
which she knew was in herself
and helped her achieve her capacity and
she is an extraordinary leader and an
extraordinary
story amber i'm talking about you
about how we form identity
and our identity doesn't necessarily
need to be formed based on the
circumstances we had no control of
our identity should be formed based on
what we know we are capable of
and the work we are determined to do
understanding the value of that hard
work
amber i'm so proud of you thank you
well hello nevada it's good to be back
and it is so wonderful to be here with
so many friends and leaders
senator catherine cortez masto
as many of you know she and i served
together
when she was attorney general of nevada
and i was attorney general of california
when we were fighting for homeowners
around the foreclosure crisis
i knew her then and saw her work i see
her work in the united states senate
when we served her four years there and
i'm going to tell you i've seen her
as a fighter when the cameras are on and
when the cameras are off
always fighting for working people in
nevada can we please hear it for kathy
and senator jackie rosen my sister in
the senate
congresswoman susie lee
congressman stephen horsford
thank you all for your leadership and
president douglas mccarron
thank you vice president frank hawk
[Applause]
and the proud members of the united
brotherhood
and sisterhood of the carpenter
so it is so great to be
in the house of labor i always know i'm
home in the house of labor and it is
great
for us to all be able to spend part of
this holiday weekend together
and of course this weekend is the
weekend where
now in particular all across our nation
high school bands will march in parades
and
families will gather for backyard
barbecues and
children will watch and wonder as
fireworks
light up our night sky and we will
celebrate together
our nation's independence indeed
[Laughter]
and this year not only will we celebrate
our independence
we will celebrate our nation's
resilience
this year america is
coming back together
because this year america is getting
back
to work
[Applause]
and just yesterday we learned that our
economy
created 850 000 jobs in june
jobs in one month
over the past five months we have
created over 1.6 million jobs
in the leisure and hospitality
industries which is so
important of course here in las vegas we
have created over three
million jobs total and wages
are going up for american workers
and for so long we've all talked
together about the fact right the cost
of living kept going up
but wages remain stagnant but we're
seeing that wages
are going up and that as we know means
we are seeing
progress and you know before president
joe biden and i
even took office we knew that the
american people were up against a whole
lot
we saw how working people were
struggling including how
this industry was getting hard hit by
this pandemic
so hard hit and we made a decision
there and then that our top priority
would be to get you relief to get
working people
relief to get checks in pockets and tax
credits in bank accounts
and with the help of this labor union
we delivered that relief and i want to
thank you on behalf of the president and
myself
for the work you did
[Applause]
and as any good carpenter would tell you
it's not how you start the job it's how
you finish
[Applause]
so i want you to know that the president
and i are determined
to keep going strong and now that we
have provided relief
to the american people we are looking to
rebuild
our nation which is another thing
carpenters know about here in nevada
there are 28 bridges in poor condition
there are more than a thousand miles of
highway
in need of repair and i don't need to
tell you this you all know it
you drive on these roads every day there
are people
in this state who do not have access to
affordable high-speed internet
or who do not have clean drinking water
coming out of their tap
carpenters work on infrastructure
projects
you work on construction projects
you know that our infrastructure
desperately needs an upgrade and an
update
right and and that's the work you do
that's the skill you have that's the
gift you give
understanding that and then being able
to actually solve the problem
if you have the support that you deserve
to get the job done and to see it
through
so the president and i are strongly
backing the bipartisan infrastructure
framework it would be the largest
long-term infrastructure investment
in nearly a century in our country it
would be
even bigger than the hoover dam
and it would create a whole lot of jobs
for carpenters
and joiners and trades people of all
kinds
carpenters we need your help
we need to get this framework across the
finish line
we need to help folks understand what's
at stake
and understand that we have an
opportunity as a nation right now
to not just recover not just to
incrementally get better but to leapfrog
into where we not only need to be but
where we
should be and where most importantly we
can be
and i want to be clear about the jobs we
will create
you may have heard that the president
and i are determined
determined to be the most pro-union
administration in our nation's history
proudly
proudly
so the jobs we create through the
bipartisan infrastructure framework
are you don't need to guess going to be
good
union jobs because
because and you all know why it's just a
reality
the reality is when workers are heard
when unions are strong
our economy is strong our nation is
strong
our people are strong it's just a
reality
so that's where we stand we're gonna get
this
infrastructure deal done we're gonna
grow our unions and support
working men and women in america
and we're gonna build like the president
likes to say we're gonna build back
better understanding all that is at
stake and again
all that we can be
now before i i finish this conversation
i also want to address
another reality and i know that senator
cortez masto talked about this
if we want to keep growing our economy
we also need to get more folks
vaccinated
we got to get more folks vaccinated
okay and you know i talked to governor
sisilak
and and frankly we got to do we got to
do better in nevada guys
we got to do better in nevada over the
past week
nevada led the nation in new covet 19
cases
and hospital admissions they jumped in
this state
and the governor has been working hard
but he needs the help
we need the help and so part of why i'm
here is to ask
the men and women of labor the
carpenters to do what you know how to do
to help us build the infrastructure
around getting folks
to get vaccinated because here's the
thing that you should know and i'm sure
you do
of these new patients the numbers i just
gave you the vast majority
were hospitalized with covid19
they were not vaccinated the vacs
the vast majority of people who have
died from covet 19
were not vaccinated so
help us to urge folks and say to them
look it's time to roll up your sleeves
and get the shot and if you already have
let's talk to somebody else we know who
hasn't
and let them know now is the time to get
this done
you know the governor has helped set up
a mobile vaccination
unit right outside of here and the
bottom line is that getting vaccinated
is safe and it is and i say this
here it is the ultimate act of
solidarity
right you know we i think all
embrace whatever our background the
spirit of love thy neighbor
and getting vaccinated is truly an
extension of that
and it's about not only our neighbor
next door
it's about the man on the side of the
street
it's about seeing in the face of a
perfect stranger
a friend and interacting with them
in that spirit so with that let me end
where i began
this weekend we will celebrate america
coming back together
and next week we will get back to work
building
up america and i'm confident we will get
that done
because as tough as this year has been
and last year was america is
tougher at every twist
and turn in ways big and small
americans have shown incredible strength
and incredible kindness and incredible
resilience i see it every day and i'll
end with this i want to share with you a
quick story
so one of my last visits here to to las
vegas um in fact it was back in march
i visited a food distribution center and
i met folks who were there in particular
i spent some time with the volunteers
who were working at the food
distribution center some
of whom had lost their jobs others who
had not but they were all volunteering
and um and so at the food distribution
center folks who were in
need of support they could drive up
and get a box of food to feed their
families and all they had to do
is to drive up and then to pop open
their trunk you know for safety reasons
there was no
physical interaction between the
volunteer and the driver and they could
pop open their trunk
so a volunteer could put the box safely
inside
and the volunteers were telling me about
how
it was often the case that the trunk
would pop
open and in this empty trunk
the volunteer you remember this steve
the volunteer would see
a handwritten note where the occupants
of the note
had written in handwriting thank you
for your labor for your work
for your kindness sometimes the
volunteers shared with me
the trunk would pop open and there'd be
a five dollar bill
from a person who lost everything
from a person who didn't have much if
anything to spare or
give
that is who we are as the american
people
a nation of people who show grace
even in times of crisis
a nation that is there for one another
a nation that is strong for one another
so let us honor that nation
today tomorrow and
every day happy fourth of july everybody
may god bless you and may god bless
america